all right so we go to uh Six Flags for  Chevys birthday right I do not like  roller coasters I am afraid of heights  and I get motion sickness so it's double  up Dove is in front of me I'm right  behind up I'm gonna see I'm [ __ ]  screaming I'm going like this mouth open  like the screaming like the top of my  lungs all of a sudden I hear Dove go  right and then literally a fraction of a  second later liquid  remember I came on the side of my face  that's what happened exactly with Dove  right now we're in the beginning we're  in the beginning of the ride it hits me  inside my face I'm locked in this  [ __ ] seat I can't get my arms to my  face to wipe off the saliva that's on my  lips and tongue from Dove so I gotta do  the rest of the ride just like  trying to blow his saliva out of my  mouth for at least 30 seconds